[Musik]
unsere helden sind dina und kevin schmid
mit ihren kindern amira und tron ihr
ziel australien der ehemalige tagesschau
moderator hans jörg enz sein abenteuer
führt ihn in den kongo monika und reto
mazzoni mit den töchtern chiara und
selina ihr neues leben beginnt im wüsten
emirat dubai sandra und danken gano die
beiden übernehmen eine farm in kanada
und theres pronet und claudio candrian
ihr traumziel ein eigenes haus auf der
karibik insel margarita
[Musik]
die stadt dorfen im süden kanadas sandra
danken gano holen auf der bank den
größten check ihres lebens ab 104 ist
rosig 407 ist
[Musik]
mit diesem scheck fast einer halben
million franken werden gar nuss ihre
neue farm bezahlen sieben jahre lang
haben sie auf einem golfplatz in der
schweiz gearbeitet jeden franken auf die
seite gelegt
solange
doz
jahre
raum und wünschen einen blog
karben
zwischen der erforschtes glauben
verloren
mit diesem prozess soll am 3
so versteckt halten
denn
endlich sandra danken kommen in ihrem
neuen zuhause an dass sie vor ein paar
monaten ausgewählt haben
[Musik]
hauptsache verbucht
die vorbesitzern sind erst vor zwei
tagen ausgezogen
[Musik]
hier wollen die garros in den nächsten
jahren von der mutterkuhhaltung leben
[Musik]
auf einem ersten spaziergang begegnen
sie ihren nachbarn kennen und turin
die bisher auf der farm gewohnt
es fühlt sich an als wären wir nur lange
in den ferien gewesen und heute einfach
nach hause gekommen
[Musik]
sie spiegeln die lücke mit davon
gekommen
[Musik]
die stadt bukavu im osten der
demokratischen republik kongo das neue
zuhause des ehemaligen tagesschau
moderators hansjörg enz
er zeigt uns radio mann der lee den
zweitgrößten radiosender in der region
und für die nächsten zwei jahre der
arbeitsort von hansjörg enz
er soll die jungen journalisten hier zur
richtigen radio profis ausbilden
das studio zwei dollar auf 70 acentic
gespielt wird über wetter aber zusehends
[Musik]
studio diskussionsrunden
da gibt es einige sehr erfolgreichen
sonntag wo sie politik besprochen worden
ist als geister groß ist ein dixi wobei
gut ist und kaufen sich eine für die
ganze folge gesendet wo wir ganz offen
lassen und wofür mein spiel die ganze
ganz wichtige
zusammen mit seinem deutschen kollegen
gibt hansjörg enz in den nächsten tagen
einen radio kurs für junge journalisten
täglich schickt er sie auf reportage und
die kollegen am hafen treffen
flüchtlinge von der anderen seite des
kivu sees ein
denn wieder einmal tobt dort ein
bürgerkrieg hansi events begleitet seine
junge journalisten auf reportage
viele sagen hier krieg gehört zum kongo
der neuen heimat von ansel
diese kids die komischerweise und jetzt
einmal die live sex leben ja welches
lebens und und nur die entweder von
boeing haben aber zu nach den gastransit
nicht da
wer dort mit anderen problemen taxiert
für afrikanische verhältnisse ist die
fähre nicht besonders von hansjörg enz
beobachtet seine jungen kollegen ganz
genau und gibt immer wieder tipps
nimm doch mal für 20 sekunden nur die
umgebungsgeräusche auf für den anfang
eines berichts im autoradio hört hansi
agent später den bericht seines radios
mandalay und muss sich wundern und
ärgern
die gebot dach und die bot sich richtig
wohl sie war richtig und michael stone
xi und und ihrer ansicht zu wenig das
ist ruft ihr boot nach dem fell
informationen also mit um sie steht
mit der frage wo kommen im wüstenemirat
dubai sind johnnys derweil auf dem weg
in ihr neues zuhause
die familie des emirates piloten
rethemer johnny ist wieder vereint
dieses hotel wird für die nächsten
monate maginnis provisorisches zuhause
sein
selina und yara können es kaum erwarten
dass drei zimmer appartement zu erkunden
das papier eto'o für die familie
eingerichtet hat
[Musik]
rentsch italienisch spanisch phänomen
ist nur zu spüren zu verkaufen
chinesische hoch
dank dass sie willkommen dubai dank
linigers widmet das picknick
[Musik]
das hotel ist umgeben von baustellen und
baulärm deswegen wünscht sich die
familie so schnell wie möglich ein
eigenes haus
juni der ehemalige swissair pilot hofft
dass sich die kinder in ihrer neuen
heimat gut einleben werden
es ist nicht so dass bereits seit 23
monaten
viele kunden mit ausländischen das ganze
mal worden
und das ist richtig aber ich danke gott
denn los wenn wir mit der antragsphase
als haupt oder
[Musik]
werden
wir haben es damals
danke
so wie es ihm egal ja
ohne masse
wow
ja so schön mit den jungs zu
strom
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die contest macht
andere hoffen stark gespräch
[Musik]
isla margarita in venezuela traumziel
für viele touristen und neues zuhause
von claudio candrian und theres brunnet
die ersten nächte in der neuen heimat
verbringen sie in einer gemieteten
wohnung
das stresst und das will er borowski
das kommt dieses da hab ich denn anders
sowie mehr nach hinten denn bald soll er
werden der traum vom eigenen haus
dafür haben der ehemalige rhb lokführer
und die postangestellte in der schweiz
alles zurückgelassen
heute besichtigen die beiden ihr
grundstück für das sie bereits
zehntausend franken an bezahlt haben
pejo ein lokaler helfer den sie bei
früheren besuchen kennen gelernt haben
begleitet sie ist sowieso das ist kultur
land
doch der hat angst dass die nachbarn
ihnen die aussicht verbauen
[Musik]
alice springs weit und breit die einzige
stadt in der wüste
knapp 30.000 einwohner neue heimat von
diener und catch me kate ist schon seit
über einem monat hier
denn er arbeitet bereits als tourguide
jetzt freut er sich dass er seine
familie wie gehabt
[Musik]
lena schmid und die kinder werden heute
zum ersten mal ihr neues zuhause sehen
der schweizer hat vor gericht folgen
jetzt gehe ich mal wo du die heilig
da wollen allerdings nicht darauf was
schwierig ist es wenn die fahrer mehr
[Musik]
alles provisorisch ist was drin nicht
nur die damen schlugen mit der
vermieterin liegt in der branche
dank des neuen jobs von apple als
touristenführer hat die familie die
chance gepackt auszuwandern
man wäre zu fertigen wie ein roter
steinberg in grußwort zur feier des
tages hatte bettina und sich eine neue
kaffeemaschine geschenkt
[Musik]
drucken sie verkaufen
der erste kaffee für tina nach einem 16
stunden reisetag
aber ich bin nach oben und dann das ist
ein flugzeug jürgen stark hat mit einer
spritze da ebenso dann ziehe ich dachte
wir stehen und dann als chris ein sixcup
makler oder zehnten minute auf der
straße bin und dann ist man froh und
dann habe ich gesagt wenn die drei autos
sie dann bin ich die großstadt und von
u2 und dann habe ich mich total aber
sieht sich jetzt darin und es ist
möglich
kaffeemaschine ist nur besser und in
bester mann war aber das sieht ein kreis
so schlimm jetzt mit biete so lang und
mehr verstecken
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite der erdkugel in
kanada herrscht tiefster winter bei
sandra und danken gallo sind es minus
zehn grad
beim spaziergang auf dem lake manitoba
vor ihrem haus wird in beiden bewusst
wie viel land sie nun besitzen 800
hektar das sind über 1000 fußballfeldern
[Musik]
das zunehmend sorgen
naja aber mehr zu essen bekommen zur
grenze abläuft dann hätten wir einen tag
das sind über 12 kilometer ausstoßen
also mit pakistan
was ihnen jetzt noch fehlt sind rund 100
mutterkühe deren kälber sie später
verkaufen wollen
die müssen sandra und danke in den
nächsten tagen finden und sie dürfen
nicht zu teuer sein
bei einem bauern in der nähe steht eine
ganze herde zum verkauf
wer einheitliche kälber damit mehr leute
was so simpel vorstellungen für prise
schwierig zum zum westen versuche aktiv
fahrerkabine reagiert duncan bringt als
ehemaliger bauernsohn etwas erfahrung
mit sie haben eine tolle rede ich würde
ihnen 530 dollar pro kabine
das ist viel zu tief die kühe hier gehen
für rund 1250 dollar pro kopf
duncan ist geschockt mehr als das
doppelte des budgetierten preises ich
kann mir über 1000 dollar pro kuh
einfach nicht leisten sonst würde es nur
noch für einen schock traktor reichen
[Musik]
sprich sitzung des ochsen
ich hoffe wir haben ja bezahlt nicht
verschwendet
haben sie sich alles zu leicht
vorgestellt
[Musik]
in afrika in der stadt bukavu im osten
des kongo ist hansjörg enz unterwegs zu
sein
[Musik]
okay das ist jetzt da wo ich wohne noch
im dezember das jetzt im unteren stock
und da ist schlafzimmer das drüben
niveau einfach stellt damit wischblätter
und sobald infizierte sie haben
der primas dass sie zur sache umsatz zu
erhöhen aber dass strom jeder tageszeit
oder so mainka laster von clever muss er
gemäss in der theorie da wo die wüste
wohnen daher mir relativ viel strom und
wir sind relativ viel wasser durch
kochen was wird da ist es wichtig
regelmäßig viel mit überhaupt nicht
bis 16 nehmen sie denn überhaupt ein
tierparadies und udo mallmann liberal
bis 13 uhr und oft mit stacheldraht und
vor zwanzig dreißig sie daheim uhr kann
dort noch eine freihändige kleber
natürlich sicherheitspakets einfach
zurückgeben av händler bereit sind halt
die waffe zu besuchen und sie therme und
sich die leute oder wohnen im uhren- und
die bankerin und wächter und das
material das er sperrt sich selber
diese wunderschöne landschaft man sich
bis auf tour
nicht so einfach zu träge hansjörg enz
lebt hier ein leben im permanenten
ausnahmezustand
seit jahren wird der kongo immer wieder
von kriegen erschüttert vieles fehlt
hier selbst alltägliche dinge muss man
lange suchen haben sie auf ems hat
gehört dass in der nähe bettdecken
verkauft werden
diese gelegenheit park der beim schopf
was haben sie ja das was bei uns im
kleidersack landet wird hier verkauft
wer den krieg ist das ein mädchen wie
heißt sie wie nathalie salamin atta das
heißt die die geliebt wird sie hat angst
vor dem motto warum hat sie angst vor
mir wegen der weißen haut
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in dubai hingegen mangelt es an gar
nichts das emirat am arabischen golf ist
seit zwei tagen die neue heimat der
familie maggioni doch auch für den
emirates piloten reto mazzoni geht der
ernst des lebens heute wieder los das
ist jetzt diese frau hat ein neues
großes flugzeug a350 von bis zu 15
minuten
was ist flugroute von dubai
der späte ko vor wieder richtig um bei
einer starken jetstream mit 180
stundenkilometern ist richtig
ausgepowert sind teilgenommen
[Musik]
die emirates piloten werden jeweils von
einem privatchauffeur abgeholt pilot ist
der traumberuf von rettung
doch eine solche karriere sagt er wäre
ohne die unterstützung seiner frau
monika undenkbar
euro für rote zahlen
eigentlich ist alles erlaubt was
passiert und am schluss sind wir
eigentlich mit zusammenstanden und ja
das ist sehr dankbar sein
wieder einmal wird reto für zwei tage
unterwegs sein
[Musik]
inzwischen versucht monika mazzoni aus
dem engen hotel appartement so etwas wie
ein zuhause zu machen
selina vermisst ihre klassenkameraden
aus der schweiz
heute schickt sie ihren schul sparen
shell co ein ganz spezielles mail
ich bin sehr sehr gut denn dubai
angekommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
als energetisch vereinigung der ost- und
der schmeckt auch sehr freuen wenn es
ansteht überraschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und auch danke
[Musik]
in venezuela soll heute der vertrag für
den landkauf unterschrieben werden für
claudio candrian und er ist ein großer
tag
die anwältin begrüßt claudio
überschwänglich claudio ist blendend
gelaunt noch
ja
[Musik]
da hat sich dann denkt
kontakt mit talent
gar nichts klappt in der kanzlei der
anwältin erwartet sieg ein
unterschriftsreifer vertrag und auch der
abgemachte preis geht plötzlich nicht
mehr
retter in der not
statt 4 6 millionen
los
unverrichteter dinge müssen sie wieder
abziehen
platz bereits jetzt der traum vom
eigenen haus
ja du jetzt will man den rechner 1000
von der trauminsel in die wüste
australiens
darauf haben die schmidts lange gewartet
heute endlich konzern hund bo mit dem
flugzeug aus der quarantäne
[Musik]
horrido diesem motto scheint den flug
nach australien und die vier wochen
quarantäne gut überstanden zu haben
[Applaus]
der zimmer komplett wieder zusammen
inzwischen geht in kanada die suche nach
kühlen für sandra und danken gallo
weiter an einer auktion wollen sie heute
zu schlagen
das macht mich nervös wer mitsteigern
wie viel und bringt und denken heute
mehr erfolg haben wird dass er gehandelt
und weil ich gerne gehört haben
duncan bietet ein frisch mit doch dann
steigen die preise immer höher zu hoch
für danken uns antrag haben sich ghettos
verkalkuliert
[Musik]
zurück in afrika im kongo für die jungen
radio journalistin ist heute ein großer
tag
ausbilder hansjörg enz überreicht den
ersten teilnehmer seines kurses heute
ihre ausbildungs diplom
wir werden ihr habt im kurs sehr hart
gearbeitet und wir haben das resultat
ihrer arbeit auf allen radiokanälen der
region gehört dafür möchte ich euch
danken
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
da ist es ganz wichtig wenn so ein kurs
statt findet dann die offizielle
eröffnung geht wo er innen und gewalt
trete und im schlussmann alle zeremonien
macher nur möglichst zertifikat macht
schluss mit dem zuruf und somit wand
hängt und das schätzen dass billiger
wird dieses universitäten
fachhochschulen und so weiterbildung
machen wie internationale partner die
ersten wirklich beschwert und die sind
richtig helfen dass die pforzheimer
einen besseren job finde das durchaus
wichtig für die riesenverluste für sie
ist
in der wüste dubais besucher john ist
die künftige schule von chiara und
selina
[Musik]
buch will
wie viel englisch verstehen die kinder
verstehen sie mich jetzt oder gar nicht
nur ein paar worte kinder aus 15 ländern
gehen hier zur schule
die direktorin zeigt das klassenzimmer
wo chiara in drei wochen zur schule
gehen wird trifft sogar ihre zukünftigen
klassenkameraden
selina kommt im januar zu euch toll ein
mädchen mehr woher kommt sie aus der
schweiz
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
für die beiden mädchen chiara und selina
ist dubai kein leichter schritt neue
schule neue sprache neue freunde die
herausforderungen so groß mit haye geht
mir das kurz gefühl für celina dass die
sehkraft du bitte genau dasselbe also
wirklich als katholische von kriegen das
gespräch als die bei diesem anfang
das ist nicht gerade mit offenen augen
flugzeuge 34 social media team ihn aber
noch ist also das team ihres pcs nicht
sagen wenn wir das sofort drauflos
stürmt die organe werden 160 liter
freilos für das man auch nicht keine
lehre und auch analysten schon gut wenn
die beziehung ist aber ich habe mit
sofort alle gut die freundin und gibt
doch und soja oder sie hat früh solche
mentalität hat
[Musik]
in venezuela steht claudio candrian ein
weiterer schock bevor ihr angeblich
schon sicheres grundstück ist gemäht
worden und plötzlich steht da ein
verkaufsschild mit einer anderen
telefonnummer gehhilfe ppr ruft an
doch unter der neuen nummer meldet sich
niemand nun ruft claudius assistent die
anwältin an die den verkauf einfädeln
sollte
es herrscht ratlosigkeit
claudio wächst das ganz ersichtlich über
den kopf zudem versteht er mit seiner
mischung aus italienisch und spanisch
nicht alles
[Musik]
diese konfusion
aber so genau dokumentiert
immer mehr leute aus dem dorf tauchen
auf und mischen sich ein
schließlich schaltet sich der lokale
polizeichef ein und erlöst das problem
auf seine weise folgen weitere böse
überraschungen mehr dazu in der nächsten
folge von auf und davon
zudem in der nächsten woche bei unseren
auswanderern lägen die nerven blank
ich hoffe ich es nicht
[Musik]
düsseldorf